peu
[Musique]
un grand bol d'air pur voilà ce qu'il
nous fallait pour aborder le délicat
sujet des films x
m
et oui ça ne concerne pas que les
spécialistes
au bord de la méditerranée à l'ombre des
rues paisibles circulent en toute
liberté et cassettes au contenu torride
[Musique]
ça s'est bien passé comment vous avez
trouvé ça pas mal que je puisse
conseiller en rien de me le demander là
vous l'avez il ya des moments que des
soirées très bien on va pouvoir pouvoir
conseiller les autres oui parce qu'elle
est celle de christian pers exane ans
mercy s'appelle comment la chine que
vous venez voir que ceux qui parlent ce
que je voudrais voir et je veux faire un
appel aux producteurs
c'est qu'ils mettent beaucoup les
dessous féminins parce que vous avez des
heures de films comme moi j'en ai vu
jeudi voir au moins une centaine
d'heures de films et toutes les femmes
sont toujours nu ils ont juste une robe
les garder je me demande aussi pourquoi
ils gardent leurs chaussures
au grau d'agde dont le milieu des
pêcheurs
il n'y a pas que les sardines et les
rascasses qui alimente les conversations
alors madame géant mais nous en garde et
quelquefois les cas cette coquine au
vous avez les filles de regarde les
abîmes et delphi solvay n'y qu'est ce
que vous voulez mémoire bord il ya de
drôles d'histoires la donne à moi je le
sois revoyait je suis plongé dans mon
tricot la télévision marge se réduit je
suppose de là mon tricot et des enfants
rires ça les amuse
[Musique]
oui de temps en temps des capitals
copine bel et bien sûr un homme moi j'en
regarde les attaques et estime que
pour nous pécheurs quand on arrive de la
mer c'est quand même un repos de
regarder un film pornographique quenum
pas à l'antenne de la télévision avec
les accidents les morts et les
assassinats à disons que moi je veux
bien de regarder ça me dérange pas nous
envoyer seul ou avec vos amis
des fois j'en regarde eux seuls et des
points avec avec des amis
parfois il vaut mieux regarder la bonne
compagnie sur tours parce que seuls ses
camarades
est ce que vous appelez bonne compagnie
et la fois ci on a une bonne fille à
côté
ces primes aillent que de le regarder
avec maurice érotique et quand même et
une histoire il ya une sage c'est quand
même plus joli qu'un film pornographique
n'ont pas déjà qu'ils se montrent déçus
cet arrêt on sait comment ça commence
mais jamais comme ça finit plus tôt on
sait comment des foules médaille parce
que des fois il faut l'amour à 2,3 et à
la fin il se retrouve à 4 5 6 il ya
toujours une porte qui sourd ou un
plaqueur et il a surtout droit
vision commune qatar semaine à peu près
comme de cassettes à eux en ce moment
pas beaucoup et je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est pas que je n'ai pas le
danger non j'aurais très bien que tu as
des cassettes
c'est que je ne trouve plus le marché
l'année dernière la dernière bombe à je
me faisais trois salles de cinéma dans
l'après midi auxerre
oui je sais le temps samedi après midi
eh bien je sortais d'un cinéma pour
entrer dans le deuxième du deuxième
tunnel ont croisé de chaque fois ce
délai mêmes acteurs ah oui j'aime bien
on avait l'impression d'être les dresser
toujours la même salle lendemain les
gens en vue de dessus de cinéma je les
leurs au cinéma par exemple ici à 7
eh bien c'est dit encore les mêmes
acteurs alors faisait quand je voyais
par exemple quatre films par semaine
quatre ou cinq par semaine avec toujours
les mêmes acteurs j'ai géré le plus
fourni et je ne veux pas je peux pas je
peux pas le fournir
il a tout vu pratiquement tous ces cas
là on essaie de s'en procurer
c'est de trouver quelque chose qui ne
connaissait pas dans des américains ou
les trucs un peu comme ça parce que tous
les teams français et les connaissent
alors si vous commencez à ce stade mais
c'est d'ordinaire c'est pas facile pour
la bonne raison que on n'a qu'un peu de
tes clients
madame n'étant pas en matière de films
ont léché question que gaël c'est de
l'auto moi je suis si fier légumes
bon alors je profite de ce caillou le
tour pour regarder des films alors
dommage que c'est le tout n'est que
linéaire mais je ne fume pas je ne bois
pas j'ai aucun vis même pas super mais
c'est le plaisir de regarder les films x
comme quelqu'un qui aime bien dans les
majeures un match de football n'ont pas
ne comprenait pas que je puisse aller au
cinéma on vendait il prononça héros
boire et regards il n'y a pas que
maintenant deux il ya une catégorie des
gens qui ne devraient pas des choses de
m chacun son truc
oui chacun son truc
dans les petits villages - des grands
vidéo club on a du sens pratique
et on s'organise comme on peut
[Musique]
et l'on s'étonne qu'un travail de vous
équiper aussi des cassettes ça fait tout
ce qu'il peut il faut le faire deux
villages au bon mais il faut porter les
siens et ce partout à la fois n'avait
pas là je le fais ça dépanne les clients
du village des montagnes ses ex de faire
des kilomètres a déclaré un vrai débat
amorcé avec les collègues s'en sort
plutôt bien
ils ont l'un et ouais merci
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut la wii
a beaucoup écouté cette cassette
je crois que c'est un film os x vous en
voyez souvent dotés en même temps
lorsque j'ai des amis qui viennent à la
maison pour passer un bon petit hommage
c'est le volant cette histoire qui est
de la vidéo là dans la boucherie c'est
assez pratique
cela évite de courir à droite à gauche
alors là je passais le petit coup de
pouce pour commander la vienne qui
aurait noté de manas sid à des films où
opèrent dans le village d'à côté le
boucher n'était pas d'accord alors le
café a pris le relais
[Musique]
ces menus bas à remettre le film se
guérir et aider
gb numéo une terreur de celui-là je
passerai à bordeaux majeur signé on est
allé voir verser
[Musique]
voilà ici les gens viennent bien de voir
un cool où le cac cfd x x des fois c'est
un film aventure quand c'est un hic
c'est qu'au statut quand même que la
cassette n'était pas vu un tireur et des
bobines et qu'à moitié ce qui prouve
bien que quand même les gens sans leur
s'est très facilement
dans les champs non plus on ne parle pas
que des prochains semis je suis
normalement sur la logique des choses
tout le monde ne pouvait en voir c'est
la nature chaque grain européenne jeunes
hormis vous avez tendance vraiment c'est
toujours pareil
non ma semaine d'essai le premier
vraiment ça surprend le soukouss allait
mieux et le troisième je ne sais pas je
n'ai eu que deux et demi exactement
alors c'est à voir mais je ne dépasserai
pas et j'irai pas faire ou 50 km pour
aller voir un film porno ça regarde
plusieurs cd gravables salle du foyer m
mais finalement ça me plaît à les
regarder mais pour rire
la veille de noël on va avec des
nouveaux pères en voir et bombay c'est
pas la veille de maille pourquoi la
veille de noël aux 2 ce soir ce soir là
bas on sort voyez pour un jeune c'est
instructif à penser de ces gens qui
tournent dans les films pornos mais je
leur tire mon chapeau parce que
personnellement je le ferai pas vous ne
voyez pas un nom en me donnerait une
grande fortune sur la table que je le
ferai pas il faut arriver à tenir le
choc là parce que il ya des coupures y
avoir des coupures ou pas je sais pas
normal y'a des chaînes qui sont pas
qu'ils sont pas naturels qui sont
analysés par ceux qui font ça comme nous
on fait le pays où vous aimeriez voir
quel genre de film un petit peu moins
osé un petit peu plus l'histoire
quoi par exemple comme histoire c'est
une belle histoire d'amour
[Musique]